non
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles
dans ce numéro reportage en pologne le
pays co organisateur de l'euro de foot
connaît une forte croissance une
situation qui détonne dans une zone euro
en crise et puis cette semaine l'europe
s'est fait très peur
on a cru un instant que la grèce allait
sortir de la zone euro il n'en est rien
pour autant ce n'est pas réglé quel
avenir pour l'europe
eh bien c'est ce que nous verrons avec
guy verhofstadt ancien premier ministre
belge et député européen
finalement les européens sont contents
les grecs ont bien voté
rendez vous compte un peu plus et il
faisait exploser la zone euro
mais pour l'heure rien n'est réglé
première étape former une coalition
puis à soupire le mémorandum ce cahier
des charges des réformes à conduire en
grèce contre le soutien de la troïka la
troïka ce triumvirat entre la bce
l'union européenne et le fmi
ces grands méchants argentier qui
étouffe le pays berceau de la démocratie
mais pas si simple assouplir ne veut pas
dire sauver et si on sauve la grèce
encore et toujours
faudra-t-il sauver l'espagne puis
l'italie la troisième puissance de la
zone euro déjà l'espagne voit ses taux
d'emprunt sur les marchés dépassé les 7%
et à rome on continue de chanter l'unité
italienne en attendant des jours
meilleurs
et pendant ce temps le monde entier
s'inquiète alors où va la zone euro
où va la zone euro ainsi un billet signé
n'aura ahmadi guy verhofstadt bonjour
bonjour alors effectivement on a le
sentiment que rien n'y fait on a beau
rajouter des milliards puis des
milliards puis des centaines de
milliards et la zone euro est toujours
en crise alors qu'est ce qui se passe je
pense qui se passe c'est que les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ont pris
pendant deux ans des demi-mesures qui
n'ont pas résolu la crise au contraire
je dirais qu'ils ont même parfois
aggravé la crise 100 milliards pour
l'espagne c'est une demi mesure selon
vous c'est des demi mesures dans le sens
que ça n'attaque pas le vrai problème de
la crise
ça donne beaucoup d'argent c'est une
somme gigantesque je dirais pour le
simple citoyen mais ce n'est pas la
cause de la clé de la cause de la crise
et le fait qu'on a créé une union
monétaire sans créer en parallèle d'une
union économique fiscale et même
politique est la conséquence est que les
marchés financiers réagissent mal à tout
mesure qui est prise par le chef de
gouvernement et des chefs d'état qui
n'ira pas dans la direction d'une
solution structurelle d'une création
d'une union fédérale en europe
alors c'est intéressant parce que vous
dites parce qu'en fait il ya quelques
années encore finalement peu de monde
disait ça c'est à dire on a 17 économies
différentes qui divergent et une seule
monnaie donc ça peut pas tenir
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors
c'est quoi le c'est quoi ce saut fédéral
dont on parle tant elles sont fédéral ça
veut dire qu'on va créer un gouvernement
de la zone euro le plus vite possible
qui peut décider des politiques
économiques fiscales même social que les
différentes états membres doivent
respecter c'est quoi ce gouvernement
sans gouvernement
c'est la commission c'est la commission
européenne est large et peut-être aussi
une comité élargi en ce qui concerne les
compétences pense qui concerne le nombre
de commissaires là je crois qu'on peut
réduire le nombre de commissaires dans
l'avenir mais ce sera une commission
avec beaucoup plus de pouvoir par
exemple une commission qui peut donner
qui peut tout de suite décidé de
sanctions contre des pays qui
n'appliquent pas la discipline
budgétaire mais c'est aussi une
commission qui peut organiser la
solidarité par exemple un marché
obligataire unique au nord
fait que on va créer on va y mettre sur
le marché des euro-obligations qui
peuvent faire baisser les taux
d'intérêts qui pour le moment sont
insoutenables pour des pays comme
l'espagne et l'italie vous vous dites
des euro obligations le plus vite
possible le plus vite possible c'est la
seule solution pour la crise autrement
va jamais sortir déclaré je sais bien
qu'il ya beaucoup de réticences en
allemagne contre cette idée at her
généré parce que pour le moment ce sont
les contribuables surtout en allemagne
qui payent la facture de tous ces fonds
de secours qu'on va utiliser d'abord
pour la grèce puis pour le portugal
maintenant pour pour l'espagne est donc
la seule bonne solution c'est créer des
euro-obligations c'est mutualiser la
dette ça ne va pas affaiblir la
discipline dans la zone euro puisque
seulement des pays qui diminue leur
dette publique peuvent participer à ce
fonds d'amortissement de la dette
lorsque vous nous dites c'est qu'en fait
il faut qu'une partie de la souveraineté
ou en tout cas des compétences des états
soient transférés ici à bruxelles ne pas
penser que c'est effectivement la
solution mais est-ce que c'est réaliste
est ce qu'un françois hollande parlante
qui vient d'être élu lé peut dire aux
français oui effectivement maintenant je
passe une partie
je pense qu'il est gay qui l'a cette
opinion là il mon premier sentiment de
l'action de françois hollande est assez
positif dans ce sens que c'est une
action pro européenne
ils n'ont pas le choix ni mme merkel ni
on entend le choix ou bien c'est la fin
de l'euro ou bien on fait le saut
fédéral est ce que ça peut se faire dans
l'est dans les semaines qui viennent
l'ania sommet européen important en fin
de mois où vous pensez qu'on ait ce saut
fédéral il est sur plusieurs années par
exemple sur dix ans lorsqu'il faut faire
c'est en fait décidé de ce saut fédéral
le plus vite possible dans les semaines
qui viennent au plus tard dans les mois
qui viennent et puis
on fait des idées d'une sorte de feuille
de route pour le réaliser dans les
années à venir
moi je suis tout à fait certain que au
moment que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement décide de se soucier des
râles tout de suite les marchés vont se
calmer
c'est ça que les marchés demandent les
marchandises vous n'êtes pas crédible
avec la monnaie unique d'une part et
puis 17 gouvernement 17 marchés
obligataires dix sept stratégies
économiques différentes et on fait la
comparaison avec les autres puissances
du monde par exemple les etats-unis ont
une dette publique est plus élevé qu'à
la zone euro le japon a une dette
publique qui est 226% de la forte
inquiétude
enfin pas de même les taux d'intérêt que
le japon paix sont des taux d'intérêt
les moins élevés au niveau mondial avec
la dette la plus élevée est la raison
très simple derrière le yen il ya une
autorité publique japonais qui qui qui
inspire du de la confiance la même chose
qu'un état fédéral avec un budget de 20
3% de son pib soutient le dollar est
chez nous quoi du sénat au gouvernement
dispersés génial alors toujours pour ce
transfert de souveraineté ou abandon de
souveraineté
est-ce que vous pensez que les peuples
européens c'est difficile parce qu'on
leur pose pas la question mais est-ce
que vous pensez que les peuples
européens sont prêts à ça c'est à dire
que quand on sait que l'europe de
bruxelles et pas très populaire c'est un
état le féminisme est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à dire bah oui et coûtait
finalement en plus alors on voit la
montée des nationalismes et ils sont
prêts à accepter sa pensée c'est vrai
qu'il ya montée des nationalismes et de
l'autre côté on je pense que la plupart
une majorité des européens est prêt
d'accepter plus europe parce qu'ils
savent très bien que le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas qui a trop
d'europe ou que l'europe est la cause de
nos problèmes
ils savent très bien que c'est qu'il n'y
a pas assez d'europe qu'on a créé la
monnaie unique qui ne veut pas perdre la
monnaie unique parce que ça va donner
des avantages énormes aux citoyens aux
entreprises en europe et ils savent très
bien qu'il faut faire maintenant des pas
en avant
chaque fois qu'il ya un eurobaromètre
qui est publié on voit quand même que
une majorité est en faveur de plus
d'europe plus d'intégration européenne
et mêmes
on a déjà demandé dans ses heureux
parents mettre l'opinion des citoyens
sur les euro-obligations et là aussi on
voit une majorité qui est en faveur
alors on va revenir dans un instant avec
vous sur ce nécessaire ce saut fédéral
il savait que l'europe a été montré du
doigt au g20 qui s'est tenue au mexique
il ya quelques jours je vous propose de
regarder ce zapping des télévisions
européennes signent et aurélie d'afas le
g20 a les yeux tournés vers l'europe la
crise bancaire et financière inquiète
les premières puissances économiques à
commencer par les états unis barack
obama a fait part de sa préoccupation
d'une possible contagion de la crise
européenne à l'économie mondiale
sa priorité pour l'europe reste la
relance de la croissance plutôt que la
restauration des comptes publics en
espagne
la journaliste s'interroge sur l'enjeu
d'un sommet dont les conclusions sont
déjà connus bien que le sommet ne soit
pas terminé on connaît déjà les détails
de la déclaration finale le projet
inclut notamment le renflouement des
banques espagnoles à hauteur de 100
millions d'euros et le texte appuie les
plans de bruxelles pour une union
bancaire
mais les préoccupations et les remarques
sur la gestion européenne de la crise
énerve le président de la commission
josé manuel barosso open des morceaux 16
nous sommes des démocraties
ce n'est pas le cas de tous les membres
du g20 mais nous nous sommes une
démocratie et nous prenons nos décisions
démocratiquement en suivant un processus
démocratique
parfois cela signifie prendre du temps
oui parce que nous sommes une union de
27 démocraties et nous devons
nécessairement trouver un consensus
et franchement nous n'avons aucune leçon
à recevoir en termes de démocratie ou
sur la façon de gérer notre économie
bon alors josé manuel barroso on a senti
un petit peu les nerfs et un petit peu
énervé il a raison je pense que non
parce que en fait ce que barack obama et
d'autres leaders au niveau mondial nous
dit c'est fait son travail créé cette
union fédérale c'est quand même une
quelque chose extraordinaire a souligné
que ce sont maintenant les américains
qui poussent les européens allaient dans
le sens d'une union fédérale à faire
beaucoup plus d'intégration européenne
et que ce sont nous les européens qui
hésitent qui n'ont pas le courage de le
faire et c'est leur intérêt aussi
c'est leur intérêt moi j'ai été à la
trésorerie américaine il ya quelques
semaines aussi à au fonds monétaire
international pour avoir des discussions
et de temps dans la trésorerie
américaine que au fonds monétaire
international ou nous on nous oublie le
plus vite de créer cette marché
obligataire unique de créer cette
gouvernement économique dans la zone
euro et on ne comprend pas pourquoi on
n'a pas encore fait cela on ne comprend
pas comme à une audace de commencer avec
l'euro sans le préparer d'une façon
appropriée vous avez été premier
ministre de belgique est ce que vous
trouvez que les gens venir vos
homologues actuels en tout cas les
dirigeants les chefs des chefs d'état
est ce qu'il manque de cette audace est
ce qu'il ya un problème de gouvernance
aujourd'hui oui mais naturellement c'est
un peu normal que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement essaye de sauvegarder leur
talent leur pour le pouvoir c'est
pourquoi je pense que c'est à la
commission européenne le plus vite
possible de déposer des paquet
législatif d'une proposition législative
sur la table du conseil
sur la table du parlement européen pour
créer cette union fédérale pour créer ce
marché obligataire unique en europe et
aussi pour représenter attaqué des
passants ce parce qu'on va jamais sortir
de la crise seulement avec de
l'austérité et nous faut de l'austérité
parce qu'il est impossible d'avoir de la
croissance économique sans des finances
publiques qui sont sains mais de l'autre
côté il faut aussi un paquet de
croissance c'est à dire des mesures pour
encourager l'investissement de nouveaux
noms
est-ce que vous pensez que la commission
européenne actuelle telle qu'elle est et
en particulier son président est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils ont le j'ai envie de
dire l'épaisseur et la force nécessaires
pour être entendue elle la commission
hésite beaucoup trop selon moi ce que je
ressens c'est que la commission ne
dépose qu'un paquet de mesures au moment
où il ya un accord complète entre paris
et berlin mais naturellement ça veut
dire que finalement ils sont en train
d'annuler leur droit d'initiative si
j'avais que dans les institutions
européennes seulement la commission
européenne comme gouvernements européens
a la droit de déposer des textes
législatifs sur laquelle alors le
conseil le parlement va se prononcer et
bien si on attend d'abord qui a le feu
vert de quelques grands prix en europe
ça veut dire qu'on annule en fait le
droit d'initiative et donc il faut
revenir un petit peu à la tradition de
jacques delors jacques delors c'était un
président de la commission qui par
exemple sur la monnaie unique sur le
marché intérieur déposait un grand plan
et puis c'était vous êtes opposé taille
au parlement d'en discuter et et dans
des batteries à la fin et y réaliser
beaucoup plus que d'attendre d'abord
l'aval de paris et berlin
vous avez parlé du couple
franco-allemand est ce dieu depuis
françois hollande est élu est-ce que ce
couple existe toujours
j'espère parce que c'est toujours
positif pour l'europe
s'il ya une bonne entente entre paris et
berlin
ceci dit ça n'aide pas seulement eux qui
peuvent décider
certainement pas quand on va faire un
saut fédéral et c'est un choix à faire
par les 27 états membres de l'union
européenne et surtout les 17 membres de
la zone euro angela merkel a fait un
appel assez fort il ya quelques jours
justement elle a parlé de nécessaire
union politique et dans un premier temps
il n'y a pas de vent véritablement une
réponse de françois hollande
est-ce que vous pensez que la france est
en train de manquer quelque chose non
c'est un peu de la tradition est un
petit peu que la france a peur d'une
union politique à tort je dirai pas ce
que ceux qui ont toujours défendu
l'idée de l'union politique c'était
aussi des français comme monnaie
schumann jacques jacques delors et je
pense que hollande veut d'abord voir
quelle est la volonté de madame merkel
pour organiser la solidarité et la
croissance dans l'union européenne et
vice et versa chez les allemands salle
inverse il s'est dit avant on se
prononce sur la plus de solidarité et
des mesures pour encourager la
croissance
on veut d'abord créer l'union politique
et pour cette raison j'ai dit qu'il faut
les deux thèses il faut la thèse de la
solidarité de la croissance qui à la
thèse la france d'aujourd'hui et il faut
aussi l'union politique qui à la thèse
allemands d'aujourd'hui qui vire au
tchad une dernière question peut-être un
peu pour pour conclure est ce que vous
vous êtes optimiste on a vu on a parlé
de la grèce en début d'émission on est
passé pas loin d'une sortie de la grèce
des choses sont pas réglés quand vous
parlez de l'europe
jetez pas vos amis à ceux qui vous dit
quoi vous dites moi je suis optimiste et
nature tout d'abord deuxièmement je
pense qu'on a une énorme chance de
réaliser cette union fédérale pourquoi
pas ce qu'est la crise et la marche et
nous pousse dans ce dans cette direction
là et on n'a pas le choix on fait ou
bien c'est le saut au fédéral
ou bien c'est la fin de l'euro et
peut-être même de l'union européenne
est-ce que c'est dans la crise on sait
que l'europe s'est construit dans les
crises mais est-ce que c'est dans une
crise aiguë qu'on peut faire quelque
chose
oui c'est toujours comme ça dans la
politique ça fonctionne comme ça ce
n'est que si les hommes politiques sont
avec le dos contre le mur qui sont prêts
à faire un saut en avant
merci beaucoup 10,04 d'avoir accepté
l'invitation d'europe les bo nous allons
maintenant partir en pologne puisque la
pologne est un pays où l'économie est
florissante avec un fort taux de
croissance
un pays qui ne connaît pas la crise donc
on va retrouver dans un instant kathia
gilder et son invité mais tout de suite
reportage à varsovie il est signé
fabrice qu'une
bienvenue chez moi à tout juste 20 ans
martin a quitté sa famille et sa
campagne pour cette résidence de la
banlieue de varsovie
car depuis deux ans il étudie dans la
plus prestigieuse école de commerce du
pays
en pologne si l'on veut réussir la
capitale est un passage obligé
le miracle économique polonais serait à
ce prix oui j'ai lu beaucoup d'articles
sur ce miracle polonais c'est vrai la
situation économique évolue bien depuis
quelques années nous les polonais on
aime bien se plaindre mais on doit
admettre que notre pays est en pleine
réussite en ce moment dans le sens où
l'on est le seul pays à ne pas être
touché par la crise
plus qu'un miracle
la pologne est un eldorado partout à
varsovie les sociétés étrangères sa
fiche et embauche dans cet immeuble
l'un des premiers français à avoir cru
en ce boom économique
c'était en 2006 six ans plus tard la
société d'ingénierie informatique de
grégoire nitot emploie 1000 salariés
dans tout le pays et comme ce matin elle
fait régulièrement la une des journaux
oui on m'a pris pour un fou et moi même
je pensais que si cinq ans après le
démarrage on serait une trentaine dans
la société ça serait une très grande
réussite était super content et cinq ans
après on était cinq cents
je m'attendais pas du tout tout le monde
vient s'implanter en pologne parce qu'il
ya différentes pour deux raisons en fait
la prendre la première c'est pour
conquérir le marché polonais marché de
40 millions d'habitants jeunes qui
consomment
deuxièmement c'est pour chercher des
solutions donc des centres
offshore aux nières shore moindre coût
que les pays occidentaux et l'a donc la
police plus à sion pour le naze et très
recherchée parce que c'est une
population fortement diplômés car
l'autre atout de la pologne c'est sa
jeunesse un peu le nez sur deux a moins
de 35 ans entre 2004 et 2007 un million
choisi de chercher du travail à
l'étranger depuis la donne a changé
on recrute de nombreux polonais qui
reviennent d'allemagne d'angleterre
parce qu'ils trouvent des niveaux de
salaires très intéressant ici notamment
à varsovie
donc c'est une chance pour ces jeunes
polonais à la chambre de commerce franco
polonaise de varsovie onu en cette
question des salaires si tu peux voir
qui encore on peut contacter les postes
très qualifiés rattrapent leur retard
mais la pologne c'est avant tout une
main d'oeuvre bon marché
800 euros c'est le salaire mensuel moyen
il reste des choses à faire c'est vrai
que chacun ait le gouvernement essaye
d'augmenter le salaire minimum pour et
on se rapproche petit à petit peut-être
pas assez rapidement pour certains d
des salaires un peu dans gti même
limitrophes la république tchèque a
quand même des salaires plus élevés que
la pologne
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu
l'envers du décor c'est vrai que pour
les jeunes c'est pas toujours facile de
trouver du travail pour trouver un
emploi seuls certains cursus sont une
garantie comme les formations techniques
ou celle d'ingénierie dans ces domaines
cette université de varsovie et la plus
réputée bon est-ce que je te prends le
rapport sur les débouchés des étudiants
merci selon ces chiffres 86 % des
étudiants trouvent un emploi dans les
six mois après leur diplôme et moins de
10% partiront à l'étranger
le résultat d'un partenariat étroit avec
les entreprises avec les nouveaux
besoins sur le marché du travail
nous avons créé de nouvelles spécialités
et nous avons ouvert de la nouvelle
faculté qui réponde mieux aux attentes
des entreprises et des étudiants
et puis au sein de l'université il ya un
conseil où siègent des grandes
entreprises
cela permet de connaître les profils
qu'elle recherche
méchaal est l'un des 33 mille étudiants
de l'université de polytechnique in est
quasiment assuré de trouver un emploi à
l'issue de sa formation
mais loin de varsovie la réalité serait
plus complexe alors il attend avant de
parler de miracle
je dirais que je suis plutôt réaliste
mais avec une dose d'optimisme pour
notre avenir
je crois profondément que dans 10 ou 15
ans la situation de la pologne sera
vraiment bien meilleure
cet avenir de la pologne dépend en
partie de l'europe
sa croissance de plus de 4% est sous
perfusion de l'union et une enveloppe de
67 milliards d'euros ces dernières
années aujourd'hui le pays est face à un
défi améliorer le niveau de vie de sa
population sans perdre de son
attractivité
une équation complexe
le miracle polonais une situation qui
détonne dans une zone euro sinistrés
pour en parler un député paul honnête
avec nous il ya deux ex alliés au cheval
ski bonjour jean teulé me suis alors
vous êtes membre du parti populaire
européen ancien ministre des affaires
européennes dans votre pays vous avez
d'ailleurs était négociateur lors des
des négociations d'adhésion de varsovie
à l'union européenne la pologne
malheureusement malheureusement ne sera
pas championne d'europe de foot
en revanche est ce qu'elle peut se
permettre au vu de sa réussite de faire
la leçon donné une leçon de politique
économique à ses partenaires c'était
chacun deux pays de choisir sa politique
macroéconomique mais le secret du
miracle polonais ce qu'on appelle mais a
prôné seller rigueur économique qu'on a
pratiqué depuis 20 ans depuis toujours
depuis la liberté a gagné on a eu la
règle d'or dans la constitution
polonaise qui nous ferons nous permet
pas de dépasser le début de la dette
les nuits des 60% et on a commencé par
un par une thérapie des chocs de batteur
beach donc le fondement de l'économie
polonaise sont saines et les regards
sont une coutume de tous les
gouvernements avec des nuances mais
depuis vingt ans les gouvernements
suivent cette philosophie politique de
l'économie scène de dépenses contrôlées
de développement de petites et moyennes
entreprises des initiatives des jeunes
et des entrepreneurs mais taux de
chômage faible croissance très fort on a
l'impression quand même qui est qui
la pologne est un cadre un peu la vision
libérale de l'europe est ce que c est ce
que c'est le cas nous sommes sortis de
du socialisme réel où il y avait des
excès du social c'est pour ça que nous
avons tourné vers une économie plus ou
plus 20 plus compétitive moins
protectrice ce qui s'avère un choix
juste dans les temps des crises ce qui
permet à la pologne l'année dernière de
voir plus que 4% de croissance
maintenant nous ralentissons un peu à
cause de la crise européenne
mais l'année prochaine cette année ce
sera toujours entre 2 à 3 % de
croissance n'avons pas connu
contrairement à la tous les pays membres
de l'union européenne
la stagnation ou la récession c'est
toujours la croissance positive alors
c'est vrai que la croissance est là en
même temps la pologne a dû compter aussi
beaucoup sur les fonds structurels
européens pour se développer
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur que ces
fonds structurels se réduisent au
détriment de certaines régions
polonaises qui offre un autre visage que
celui qu'on a à varsovie et qui risquent
de souffrir de cette réduction probable
des fonds européens
nous profitons de la politique de
cohésion
c'est un facteur qui nous aide nous
profitons beaucoup moins que les anciens
comme l'espagne comme ils rendent parce
que la générosité plus limité mais il
faut dire que tout ce que nous recevons
comme comme cohésion confort structurel
ça revient 60 à 80% sérésien au prix de
l'europe occidentale donc c'est un
stimulus économique cent pour l'ensemble
parce que ce sont les entreprises de
leurs occidental qui qui travaillent
chez nous aussi donc c'est au profit de
la croissance paneuropéenne s'est pas
seulement avec le diplôme est ce qu'ils
en profitent
vous invitez les pays à venir en pologne
dans ce ce qui passe pour la main'
dorado trop de dire de la pluie et
eldorado mais messieurs d'une économie
saine qui profitent du grand marché
enfin qui est compétitive qui est jeune
qui est dynamique et qui a l'ambition de
conquérir les marchés orientaux de l'ex
union soviétique
alors on était allé voir à quoi
ressemblent et varsovie
en revanche si on fait 50 cent
kilomètres plus loin la situation n'est
pas tout à fait la même notamment dans
certaines régions du sud
elles sont encore en développement nous
sommes toujours un pays relativement
pauvre
mais les décalages entre nous entre la
moyenne de l'union européenne serait
serre s'est réduit depuis l'entrée
européenne même même avant parce que en
partant de haut niveau c'est assez bas
ce qui est la faute de
la division tragique qui altan du
continent européen on rattrape avec
l'énergie même et travaille avec tout ce
qui est le profit le bénéfice de la
participation dans l'union européenne
et vous n'êtes pas inquiet de ce qui se
passe chez vos partenaires est ce que
dans ce contexte
la pologne a toujours envie de rejoindre
d'adopter la monnaie commune de
rejoindre la zone euro voulons rejoindre
nous regardons ce qui se passe avec
inquiétude nous faisons partie de ces
grands de cette grande entité économique
qui est l'union européenne elle nous
supportons les conséquences
donc notre croissance ralentit aussi à
cause de l'ensemble de l'union
ralentissant nous sommes liés par par le
pari commerce pour un investissement
assez d'erreurs et 70% de nos banques
appartiennent aux banques de l'europe
occidentale
donc en fait nous comprenons pas
pourquoi on doit où certains veulent
diviser l'europe ans de l'eurozone et le
reste parce que la crise c'est la crise
des de l'excès d'endettement ce pas la
crise de la monnaie commune
on veut joindre la monnaie commune quand
les comptes et le cerf assène et quand
nous serons prêts et nous nous faisons
tout pour être prêt au plus tôt le plus
de huit sur vous vous dites le secret de
la réussite polonaise c'est qu'elle a
appliqué des recettes strict depuis
qu'elle a rejoint l'europe
est ce que cette croissance est
véritablement solide ce qui n'a pas de
risques comme cela s'est produit en
espagne ou en irlande aux crises
immobilières par exemple ou dans bâle
nos banques sont très seuls
relativement par rapport à tout ce qui
se passe sur hier nous avons pas d excès
in oubliée quand n'avons pas des
situations qu'on pourrait comparer aux
situations espagnoles italiennes et
grecques portugaises ou irlandaises
relativement mais nous souffrons en
termes d relentissement parce que nos
marchés dans l'europe occidentale la
vieille europe s'il voulait se
rétrécissent pour terminer cette
émission trois mots quels conseils
donneriez vous aujourd'hui au aux
espagnols aux italiens dans mon français
qui ont qui sont endettés à des niveaux
extrêmes pour avoir un succès peut-être
au début dans un simple moment il faut
souffrir mais sa porte des résultats
doublé rigueur économique sur la base de
l'économie scène delà des économies
dynamiques et bien ce sera le mot de la
fin merci beaucoup il ya sec sérieuse
wolski d'avoir été avec nous on voulait
se retourner dans l'hémicycle et nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine à
bruxelles très bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires